now to breaking news out of the
weaponized and politicized FBI of Joe
Biden a brand new report from
foxnews.com revealing that the bureau's
targeting of Catholics was far worse
than the FBI director Ry would have you
believe as a part of its Federal fishing
Expedition into so-called traditional
Catholics the FBI apparently inter uh
interrogated at least one priest and a
choir director with the latest on this
he is the chairman of the very important
house Judiciary Committee Jim Jordan is
with us okay choir director really yeah
so how bad did this get well first they
told us it was just one field office the
Richmond field office then we learn that
oh no no it was bigger than that it was
multiple field offices involved in this
attack on prolife Catholics and now we
learn as you pointed out Sean that the
FBI was talking to a priest and a choir
director now again remember the larger
context this is the same FBI that spied
on President Trump's campaign this is
the same FBI that censored Americans
this is the same FBI on this particular
issue that went to Mark Hal's home a
pro-life Catholic arrested him in his
home in front of his wife and seven
children when that case goes to court
Mark Hal wins which is that's how
ridiculous this all is so that's what
our report spells out thebi wasn't being
square with us so you
subpoenaed documents that you had that
you subpoenaed show there was no
legitimate basis for the memor to insert
federal law enforcement into Catholic
houses of worship then why did they do
that this this whole mind remember when
Joe Biden stood in front of Independence
Hall and talk about how one half of the
country is fascist and we got it's this
whole mindset if you're if you're
pro-life if you're a traditional
catholic somehow you're radical somehow
you're an extremist remember this is
part of the justice department that said
if you're a mom and dad going to a
school board meeting you're an extremist
as well so this is the mindset this is
what's so scary and this is why we don't
want to give them more money for a new
headquarters and why we've formed this
committee to look at all the things they
have done in this area and of course in
the censorship area can I ask you in
light of what happened in the summer of
2020 574 riots uh dozens of dead
Americans thousands of injured cops hit
with bricks rocks bottles Molotov
cocktails billions in property damage
there was no committee set up for those
riots uh Congressman uh and yet we're
using limited resources of of the FBI
for this that's that's that's what
they're investigating why didn't they
use the videotape of all those people
involved in the riots in the summer of
2020 uh and have a committee like the
January 6 committee right because we've
been consistent you've been consistent
we've condemn violence every time it's
happened we said it was wrong in the
summer of 2020 and those who committed
violence on January 6 we said that was
wrong but here's this FBI I use the
example again of of Mark Hal praying in
front of an abortion clinic they decide
to go into his home ARR he was willing
to turn himself in his Council said so
and they go into his home arrest him in
front of his wife and children that is
not how you're supposed to operate in
this great country again it's it's why
we're doing the work we're doing and
making sure we get the facts out there
and beginning to change its behavior Can
we can you tell me why and how this is
happening um when you think of the FBI's
involvement in you know in terms of in
the leadup to the election in 2020 and
the FBI was meeting months before with
all the big Tech corporations warning
them they may be victims of a
disinformation campaign about Joe and
Hunter Biden uh and lo and behold they
by the way they knew Rudy Giuliani had a
copy of Hunter's laptop they knew that
story was going to break then when
Facebook and Twitter asked for
confirmation is this real or not they
would not answer uh when in fact they
knew it was absolutely real uh why do
you think they did that and why is not
anybody being held accountable why is
the FBI now for two presidential Cycles
in a row in the case of James Comey
protecting Hillary and emails Etc why
why is the FBI getting involved in our
elections I think the reason it did that
particular case because it inv involved
Joe Biden's son it's the same reason we
have a fiveyear investigation in the
hunter Biden and they had to go to a
special Council after five years of
investigating I I actually think that
whole case I think they'd have got away
with it I think it all been cleared
through but for two Brave whistleblowers
who by the way are going to give more
information to the Ways and Means
Committee tomorrow but for shapley and
Ziggler I think they get away and and
for that judge in Delaware I think the
reason they did it all was because it
was about the bidens that's the whole
point here so that that that is why I
think they they did and it was worse yet
Sean the US attorney in Pittsburgh who
was supposed who was supposed to be the
Clearing House for all information in
2020 relative to Hunter Biden and
Ukraine when we deposed Mr Brady he told
us that when I asked him I said when did
you find out about the laptop you think
that's pretty important information
they'd have told the US attorney who was
supposed to be the guy in our government
who filters that information clears it I
asked him when did you learn about the
laptop he said when the story went
public did the FBI in in 2016 protect
Hillary Clinton are they applying a
different standard in terms of
classified information now to Donald
Trump number one and in 2020 when they
were were talking to Big tech companies
did they sensor information they knew
was true did they actively work to do
that we have 20 second well they kept it
from Scott Brady so I sure think they
did and of course in 2020 it was worse
than what you described because they
spied on President Trump's campaign for
goodness
sake unbelievable I just this has to be
fixed if we're going to ever have equal
justice under the law Jim Jordan thank
you sir hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most comp in analysis you will not
get it anywhere
else